bienvenue à tous sur les chaînes
parlementaires seller de parlement hebdo
avec marion roger marion mazauric elle
va tout va bien dans l'actuelle
politique et parlementaire cette semaine
trois jours de visite aux états unis
pour françois hollande au programme une
conférence de presse avec barack obama
un déplacement dans la silicon valley
seule ombre au tableau pierre gattaz
patron des patrons a invité dans les
bagages du président il a jeté le
trouble à propos du pacte de
compétitivité serge dassault perd son
immunité parlementaire ses parents vote
à main levée que le bureau du sénat a
pris cette décision demandée par la
justice dans le cadre d'une enquête sur
des achats présumé de voix à
corbeil-essonnes le sénateur et
industriel dit vouloir à présent prouver
son innocence et puis dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission place à un film
d'animation à la française une fable
écolo à destination des enfants tan
tilda sortie en salles cette semaine ou
l'histoire d'une femme de 40 ans en
lutte contre l'industrie agroalimentaire
la françois de rugy bonjour bonjour vous
êtes engagé depuis 25 ans dans
l'écologie vous êtes aujourd'hui
coprésident du groupe écologiste à
l'assemblée nationale avec un barbara
pompili écouter justement comment elle
et vos collègues députés vous
définissent c'est un partenaire très
loyal de la majorité françois de rugy
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille d'abord
c'est un présente groupe e qui
travaillent c'est un c'est quelqu'un de
quelqu'un qui compte dans le parlement
des sujets des désaccords profonds avec
lui naturellement je suis pas écologiste
mais mais voilà j'ai du respect pour son
travail compétent compétents ils bossent
et puis une bonne vision politique ça
fait des années que il a tracé une ligne
qui à une époque dans le parti n'était
pas forcément majoritaire sur le fait
que là il faut qu'on passe des alliances
canton une force minoritaire c'est un
passionné de politique c'est un bosseur
c'est quelqu'un qui a envie d'avancer
qui a envie d'apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice qu'on est en train de
construire petit à petit ici c'est un
écologiste convaincu et c'est quelqu'un
qui a un enthousiasme communicatif
sur le plan politique je me sens pas
nécessairement très très proches parfois
je le plains comme barbara pompili
d'ailleurs parce que d'être co
présidents comme elle co présidente d'un
groupe ça doit être difficile ça il ya
un petit proverbe populaire qui dit a
jamais deux crocodiles dans le même
marigot alors est-ce si compliqué à la
coprésidence à françois de rugy quand
ils n'ont pas du tout d'abord parce que
nous n'avons pas les mentalités de
crocodile justement et surtout nous
avons voulu faire cela pour que tout le
monde comprenne bien que le groupe
écologiste était un groupe strictement
paritaire il ya autant d'hommes que de
femmes nous sommes assez attaché à cette
idée ou le savez nous avons été
pionniers en la matière en fait
actuellement les 30 ans des verts bien
il ya trente ans les verts portait déjà
cela est à l'époque tout le monde était
contre sens non seulement nous rient au
nez monde était contre et on l'a fait on
a pour la première fois de notre
histoire un groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nous avons voulu que ça se
voit qu'il y avait cette particularité
est pareil on s'entend très bien parce
que évidemment une coprésidence ne
marche que si les deux personnes
s'entendent bien alors vous avez fêté
les 30 ans des verts fin janvier vous
étiez l'un des premiers à prôner
justement des alliances avec la gauche
au départ le parti est partie d'une
stratégie d'indépendance vers ses
alliances est-ce que cela a servi la
cause écologiste au sens large oui moi
je pense que les écologistes si on
restait tout seul dans notre petit coin
ne serait rien il faut évidemment
participer aux responsabilités et en
démocratie on participe jamais
responsabilité tout seul 1c c'est un
mythe de penser car partie à lui tout
seul pourrait contrôler mais en plus les
écologistes sont pour l'instant un parti
minoritaire il faut bien le dire les
électeurs ne nous ont jamais confié la
majorité ou même d'être le plus grand
parti dans une coalition nous le
souhaiterions moi je le souhaite je
pense qu'un jour ça se produira mais en
attendant ne va pas rester les bras
ballants donc c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
toujours souhaité qu'on prenne nos
responsabilités y compris dans des
alliances au logis comment va le moral
si on en croit vos amis socialistes pas
la grande forme c'est vrai que la
situation est difficile la situation
d'abord à économique et social moi je
pense qu'avant de se lamenter sur la
situation politique faut quand même que
l'on soit bien conscient que la france
ne va pas bien la situation économique
on parle des chiffres de la croissance
qui sont un petit peu mais deux dans la
majorité aussi
la situation politique est elle est
aussi du coup à l'image de cette
situation difficile puis c'est vrai que
depuis maintenant bientôt deux ans la
ligne politique suivie par le président
le gouvernement n'a pas toujours été
claire elle a donné l'impression d'être
un peu nous voyante donc ça n'a pas
contribué à rendre les choses faciles
dans la majorité par exemple on va
commencer cette semaine politique si
vous le voulez bien avec un meeting un
retour vous voyez de qui on veut parler
nicolas sarkozy a donc assisté à son
premier meeting depuis 2012 et à geste
fort de soutien pour la candidate à la
mairie de paris nathalie kosciusko
morizet thibault le floch étaient sur
place
contrairement aux apparences non ce
n'était pas un meeting de nicolas
sarkozy
pas un petit mot je suis là par amitié
pour la terminer par amitié par
solidarité pour elle
l'ancien président a fait le déplacement
hier soir dans le 11ème arrondissement
pour soutenir son ex porte parole de la
campagne présidentielle
désormais candidate à la mairie de paris
un soutien de poids pour nathalie
kosciusko morizet qui a deux avantages
la présence de nicolas sarkozy a
démultiplié l'attention médiatique
autour de ce meeting et l'équipe de nkm
espère que cela redonnera un coup de
fouet à la campagne de leur candidat on
voyait bien quand même que les
difficultés que nous avons connues dans
l'établissement des listes bas nous
empêchait véritablement de creuser un
écart avec les partis de gauche au
pouvoir qu'en réalité toute la france
est en train de progresser de ce point
de vue là et qu'on avait besoin d'une
impulsion supplémentaire je crois que
nicolas sarkozy est arrivé au bon moment
quand il fallait où il fallait nicolas
sarkozy justement était au premier rang
mais il n'a pas pris la parole à la
tribune nathalie kosciusko morizet elle
n'a pas manqué d'adresser un clin d'oeil
à son invité de marque j'ai l'impression
que c'est presque nicolas qui aurait pu
me la prendre dans la vie ce qu'on prend
à beaucoup plus de saveur que ce qu'on
vous donne
c'est un très beau geste qui fait c'est
moi je sais que je peux compter sur son
amitié mais là il vient en quelque sorte
pour pour qu'on la partage avec tous
ceux qui sont là avec tous les parisiens
qui était ce soir au gymnase japy
étaient très nombreux
un geste d'amitié donc de l'ancien
président qui a renoué l'espace d'une
soirée avec l'arène politique
bon alors si vous aviez un doute sur le
retour de nicolas sarkozy des levées moi
j'ai jamais doute quand j'étais député
dans l'opposition j'ai eu l'occasion de
le rencontrer trois fois avec un groupe
de parlementaires de la majorité de
l'opposition travaillons à l'époque sur
la crise et je suis toujours été
convaincu que c'était d'abord et avant
tout un animal politique que se serai
plus fort que lui d'ailleurs là je pense
que c'est ce qu'on voit c'est plus fort
que lui peut pas s'en empêcher jal à
françois son camp hausse et surtout je
crois c'est aussi le plaisir qu'il prend
à ce que des gens là clame parce qu'on a
bien vu que c'était lui qui était
acclamé bien plus que madame kosciusko
morizet en revanche j'entends que même à
droite il ya des gens qui trouvent que
ça commence à faire un peu beaucoup
cette façon de dire non non moi je suis
retiré de la vie politique et de
multiplier les apparitions notamment d'
instrumentaliser même les concerts de sa
femme ce qui est un pote que voilà la
campagne pour paris match réalisé il ya
plus de doute haussier oui mais ça en
revanche je pense que c'est une erreur
c'est à dire que les élections
municipales ce sont des élections
municipales d'ailleurs les sondages sur
paris montre que les parisiens et
parisiennes ce qu'ils veulent c'est
qu'on leur parle de paris est
manifestement jugée les projets pour
paris justement c'est difficile pour le
candidat écologiste en ce moment à paris
christophe nadjovski oui mais c'est
toujours difficile quand il y a une
tension médiatique une attention
médiatique qui est porté d'abord et
avant tout sur deux candidates c'est
difficile de faire exister un autre
candidat une autre liste avec un autre
projet mais je crois que les parisiens
et les parisiennes plus justement ils
vont se rapprocher de l'élection
municipale comme dans les autres villes
de france plus ils auront envie de juger
les propositions concrètes pour leur
ville et le projet écologiste qui est
porté par christophe nadjovski sur paris
c'est un projet extrêmement pertinent
concret quand vous voyez par exemple
cette idée d'avoir un tramway le long de
la seine voilà ça c'est des choses qui
vont servir la vie quotidienne des
parisiens comme tout ce que les
écologistes proposent dans les
municipales anne hidalgo a teinté son
programme d'écologie est ce que c'est
suffisant dans son programme il ya
toujours la volonté dans les discours
comme vous dites
dit très bien de teinté de vert les
discours est le problème c'est de passer
à l'acte on le voit dans la politique
nationale comme dans la politique locale
christophe nadjovski sur paris par
exemple il a dit bah il ya eu une alerte
à la pollution qui a duré quand même
très longtemps à paris et dans d'autres
villes de france il a proposé la
circulation alternée et la n'y avait
plus personne alors dans la suite de la
semaine politique à mardi la journée a
été marquée par la visite du chef de
l'état aux états unis
françois hollande s'est donc rendue
trois jours aux états unis au programme
de la visite d'état une conférence de
presse commune avec à barack obama pour
évoquer la situation internationale un
dossier sur lequel la france et les
etats unis sont en accord barack obama
et françois hollande ont multiplié les
démonstrations d'amitié seule ombre au
tableau pierre gattaz patron des patrons
invité dans les bagages du président qui
a jeté le trouble à propos du pacte de
compétitivité françois moulin
pierre gattaz est en colère et il le
fait savoir invité dans la délégation
qui accompagne françois hollande aux
états unis le patron du medef a dit tout
le mal qu'il pensait du pacte de
responsabilité du président de la
république il n'y a pas de contreparties
prévues par le medef en échange de la
baisse des charges pour les entreprises
au lendemain d'un séminaire du parti
socialiste sur la question est alors que
le ps s'est lui même divisé sur le sujet
le gouvernement n'a pas très bien
accueilli la critique
je souhaite que monsieur gattaz quand il
sera revenu en france rencontre le plus
vite possible les organisations
syndicales comme c'était prévu pour
engager le dialogue social vraiment sur
le pacte c'est très attendu donc je
pense que le décalage horaire parfois
peut poser des problèmes au sein de
l'ailé gauche du ps c'est la
consternation ceux qui justement avait
profité de la réunion d'hier pour
demander que des contreparties concrètes
en termes d'emploi et de salaire soit
imposée aux entreprises sont aujourd'hui
sceptique je le sens mal ce pack parce
que je ne sais même pas aujourd'hui si
vu l'état d'esprit du medef cramponné à
sa cupidité et sa volonté d'avoir des
chèques en blanc et sans engagement au
service de l'emploi je sais même pas
s'il va aller au terme du processus
envisagé
l'ump elle se félicite que le medef met
des bâtons dans les roues du
gouvernement et de ce projet de pacte
que l'opposition juge un plat on arrête
de réfléchir à imaginer des
contreparties c'est d'abord de baisser
les charges de redonner de la
respiration à notre économie ça n'est
pas d'inventer des contraintes
supplémentaires aux entreprises il faut
qu'une fois pour toutes on comprenne ça
l'économie ne fonctionne pas comme ça ça
n'est pas en tapant sur la tête des
entreprises qu'on va y arriver pierre
gattaz rencontrera les organisations
syndicales dans quelques jours pour
discuter d'un plan d'action dans ce
climat tendu il a promis de proposer non
pas des contreparties mais des
engagements en matière d'emploi
c'était donc mardi depuis pierre gattaz
est revenu sur ses propos françois de
rugy est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un pacte
de responsabilité sans contrepartie
chiffres et il faut qu'il y ait des
contreparties d'ailleurs le président de
la république va être chiffrés ben oui
écouter le medef lui même avait parlé au
départ de 100 milliards d'euros de
baisses de charges et de cotisations et
un million d'emplois créés en cinq ans
bon moi je fais un calcul simple si on
est sur 30 milliards ça fait trois cent
mille bon je vois pas pourquoi d'un seul
coup le medef est aux abonnés absents
essaye de se défausser de ce défilé moi
ce que j'ai surtout l'impression que ça
me donne c'est que en fait le medef avec
pierre gattaz a dit on va être un medef
de combat mais là c'est même plus un
ménage de combat c'est une espèce de
partis d'opposition je crois que là
l'économie française les entreprises
françaises a nommé de pas cela est
d'ailleurs mois les entreprises que je
rencontre des chefs d'entreprise que je
rencontre ils ne tiennent pas ce
discours là que contraindre obligé c'est
pas fait pour lui un bon rapport de
force avec avec les entreprises
notamment
le bon vocabulaire mais quand vous
parlez de pacte vous ne parlez pas de
contraindre d'obliger vous parlais
justement dans cet endroit que le medef
c'est ce qu'ils disent oui mais j'ai en
contrepartie veut dire contrat aurait
coûté la droite moi je veux bien mais
enfin la l'économie française elle a
décroché depuis 2002 1 ça fait dix ans
que plus de dix ans que la compétitivité
française décroche donc je pense que la
droite devrait être discrète par
ailleurs sur les économies des dépenses
qu'il faudrait baisser c'est pareil
elles ont explosé pendant lé quinquennat
précédent donc là aussi faisons preuve
de modestie c'est pour ça que moi je dis
100 milliards c'était quand même un peu
dans le monde 2 je sais pas d'où mais
pas dans le monde réel dans le monde
virtuel peut-être sur la lune mais pas
dans le monde réel donc là on propose 30
milliards c'est un effort énorme si on
doit le faire financer entièrement par
des économies c'est un effort très
important ou alors c'est le déficit
aussi qui va repartir à la hausse il
faut quand même être concret sur ces
choses là je sais que il faut moi je
suis convaincu qu'il faut faire quelque
chose pour la compétitivité des
entreprises je suis convaincu qu'il ya
une question autour du coût du travail
qu'on ne peut pas éluder mais on ne peut
pas s'envoyer comme ça des espèces de
revendications un jour et puis quand on
dit bart entrons dans la négociation
alors là le medef repart culture
d'origine en l'état est ce que vous
voterez vous la confiance sous couvert
de mort telle qu'elle a été demandée par
le président de la république ben nous
on est là on est dans le gouvernement
donc on va pas voter la censure du
gouvernement il faut quand même être en
revanche pour ce qui est du contenu de
ce pacte de connexion est encore besoin
de savoir vraiment de bien dessiné les
contours ce qui pour l'instant n'est pas
totalement le cas disons le mal est
toujours la cour des comptes a présenté
son rapport annuel sur l'utilisation des
deniers publics est presque comme
d'habitude l'institution exhorte le
gouvernement réduire davantage les
dépenses publiques écouter didier me
nous constatons je tiens à le dire un
effort considérable de notre de notre
pays pour mieux maîtriser la
les comptes publics mais les résultats
sont sont
plus plus plus limité plus lent qu'il
n'était prévu il ya un risque sur 2013
que
l'objectif de déficit de
4,1 pour cent soit dépassée
parce que la croissance n'est pas celle
qui était prévu parce qu'il y a
eu également un calcul un peu optimiste
des prévisions de recettes alors cette
fin de semaine on a appris que l'insee
avait revu un peu la croissance à la
hausse pour 2013 à 0 3% au quatrième
trimestre c'est une éclaircie mais je ne
parlais pas de quoi encore sauter au
plafond non c'est évident que la
situation économique reste très
difficile et je pense que honnêtement ça
sert pas à grand chose de faire beaucoup
de commentaires sur +0 1 - 0 1 2 sur la
vérité c'est quand même que depuis la
crise depuis le déclenchement de la
crise et maintenant plus de cinq ans
nous n'avons toujours pas retrouvé le
niveau de production qu'il y avait avant
la crise alors que d'autres pays l'ont
fait donc c'est ça qui est vraiment
cette question là qu'il faut s'opposer
lancer parce que je pense que l'économie
française elle est un peu sous
l'éteignoir on peut pas dire on n'a pas
connu tant mieux des récessions
violentes comme d'autres pays mais du
coup c'est une espèce de stagnation dans
la durée et ça on ne peut pas s'y
résigner il n'y a pas de fatalité à cela
nous ce que nous pensons c'est que se
fixer des objectifs de déficit à 3 % ça
c'est complètement hors de propos ce qui
compte c'est de s'engager dans une
trajectoire ça c'est vrai dans une
trajectoire de réduction des déficits et
non plus oui mais il faut arrêter de se
fixer les objectifs qui sont intenables
parce que du coup c'est 3% fin octobre
évidemment que c'est intenable le même
pour 2014 enfin vous avez vu ce que dit
le président de la cour des comptes sur
2013 mais si on nous avait parlé vous
souvenez pas ce que dit le ministre de
l'économie lui été frappé de 3% l'année
prochaine c'est pas crédible et c'est
pas sérieux et moi je le regrette et je
pense que la parole justement politique
sur l'économie a perdu beaucoup de
crédibilité à cause de ses déclarations
successives je rappelle qu'en septembre
2012 on nous a fait voter nous on n'a
pas voulu le bottin le traité européen
qui était censé âprement la discipline
budgétaire on allait voir ce qu'on
allait voir et puis on a les six derbies
3% en 2013 en 2013 on devait faire 3% ce
sera plus de 4% donc il faut revenir sur
des choses sérieuses réaliste oui il
faut réduire les déficits dans la durée
mais si on fait des impôts
supplémentaires encore pour réduire les
déficits en fait ils vont s'aggraver
parce que là l'économie va être encore
plus sous l'étouffoir alors justement la
cour des comptes m et des
recommandations des préconisations
est-ce qu'il faut les suivre notamment
par exemple ralentissement des dépenses
de santé gel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires disons que la cour des
comptes elle est là pour éclairer nos
choix elle est là dans son rôle mais
c'est pas la cour des comptes qui fait
la politique économique et budgétaire
ce sont de bonnes pistes il ya des
choses qui sont des bonnes pistes oui
par exemple sur les dépenses de santé
l'idée de faire appel davantage aux
médicaments génériques de faire
davantage vous savez c'est un peu
compliqué mais ce qu'on appelle
l'hospitalisation ambulatoire
c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu d'aller passer
une nuit ou plusieurs nuits à l'hôpital
va peut-être vous pouvez avoir une
opération est rentré chez vous le soir
c'est en plus un gain je pense pour les
façonneurs non ça je crois que alors là
ces mesures là justement on en touche
mais si on croirait mais si on est
uniquement des espèces de vue sur tout
ça de 2,2 de rabot généralisé mais qui
ne s'attaque pas aux structures alors là
je pense que en effet on arrivera on n'y
arrivera jamais moi je plais bien
longtemps pour que des réformes de
structure la décentralisation et la cour
des comptes le dit aussi le président de
la république relancer la
déconcentration qui disons le étaient à
l'arrêt c'est fondamental d'aller au
bout ça ne va pas produire d'ailleurs
évidemment des économies mais l'année
prochaine on s'était en revanche d'ici
trois ans quatre ans cinq ans là ce sera
durable
le point d'indicé des fonctionnaires
mais c'est pas que c'est une question
d'un tabou c'est que c'est concret est
ce que le pouvoir d'achat des
fonctionnaires touchés dont on discute
je les prenais attendait non mais et le
point d'indicé il est gelé et déjà il a
déjà été gelé plusieurs années de suite
ce qui est en cause c'est d'essayer d'en
rajouter à cela le stopper les
avancements aussi volé pour les agents
publics
quelle que soit leur catégorie enfin je
rappelle que les agents de catégorie c
c'est des petits salaires s'il doit
avoir non seulement aucune augmentation
de salaire générales mais aucun
avancement alors là évidemment que ça va
finir par créer une tension forte et à
juste titre dans la fonction publique
alors mardi toujours jean marc ayrault a
convoqué une réunion interministérielle
sur l'intégration en dossier explosif
après plusieurs rapports qui avait fait
grand bruit une feuille de route a été
adoptée avec deux axes l'accueil et la
lutte contre les discriminations le
premier ministre a par ailleurs répondu
à ceux qui l'accusent par don d'attiser
le vote communautaire écoutez le et il
n'est pas question pour la gauche de
renoncer à traiter cette question au
prétexte que des opposants ou des
commentateurs cherche à
l'instrumentaliser à tout prix
ce que nous voulons démontrer avec cette
feuille de route
que nous avons adopté cet après midi
c'est que nous voulons traiter
sereinement de façon apaisée cette
importante question pour le vivre
ensemble des français
françois de rugy ce devait être un gros
chantier finalement découvre des mesures
consensuelles pas de moyens
supplémentaires vous êtes déçu
surtout je pense que là aussi ça montre
que la méthode qui avait consisté à
commander des rapports souvenait qu'il
ya eu des polémiques des retours de ces
rapports n'est pas une bonne méthode
parce que ce site du tout manuel valls
attend rappel oui par ailleurs il eut
aussi ça mais je dire que c'est un sujet
en effet
grave les discriminations mais il ya
aussi par ailleurs la question du vivre
ensemble ça apparaît un peu théorique
mais c'est une réalité bien concrète
dans les villes les quartiers les
villages de france on voit bien qu'il ya
des crispations des crispations
identitaires de différentes formes
religieuses pour certains autour de
l'identité nationale pour d'autres même
autour de la famille etc ça peut se
comprendre par certains côtés parce que
le monde change donc le réflexe de
vouloir se crisper sur l'existant ou
même sur un monde qui est en train de
devenir complètement bouleversé mais en
même temps leur responsabilité du
politique c'est de remettre je pense les
choses en perspective oui notre société
a évolué oui ce n'est pas quelque chose
de 2 qui doit être dramatique bien au
contraire il ya des aspects très
positifs
il faut le faire essayer de le faire
sereinement ce n'est pas facile le front
national instrumental ça à longueur de
journée mais c'est pas pour autant
d'effet le 1er liste à raison qu'on doit
arrêter d'en parler plus tard et était
le sujet vous savez à donner ne fait pas
faire renvoyer à plus tard dommage oui
c'est un peu dommage on sur le cv
anonyme je pense qu'on a été nombreux y
compris parmi les parlementaires de tous
bords a plaidé pour ça et c'est pas une
recette miracle non plus faut pas croire
que ont uniquement parce que comme ça on
efface le nom on va effacer tous les
problèmes qui sont plus structurelles
moi je pense par exemple que l'école un
rôle fondamental à jouer que la crise de
l'école là ça c'est une crise
extrêmement inquiétante avec le recul
des résultats de l'école est par
ailleurs on le voit les inégalités
maintenant l'école devient plutôt un
facteur d'aggravation en quelque sorte
des inégalités c'est un comble alors que
la volonté de la république française a
toujours été de faire de l'école un lieu
d'émancipation
le dress du français pour avoir un titre
de séjour oui mais ça me paraît tout à
fait légitime bien sûr mais moi je crois
d'ailleurs valls qui se propose c'est
bien oui bien sûr mais objet moi j'ai
fait un jour un voyage en israël israël
c'est un pays d'immigration cc c'est 100
% des immigrés succès si il en arrive
tout le temps et le pays cherche à en
avoir pour tout un tas de raisons y
compris critiqua mais c'est ainsi et
bien la première chose qu'ils aient fait
moi j'ai demandé aux israéliens de chine
comment vous faites il ya des tensions
et d'ailleurs forte vous sein de la
population israélienne mais il y à cette
volonté les six premiers mois alors
l'obligation d'apprendre la langue et on
y met des moyens mais ça contribue
évidemment à ce que les gens puissent
vivre ensemble le décor est manuel valls
et d'offres
marié bien sûr elle va passer au
mercredi le sénat les de l'immunité de
serge dassault
la troisième a été la bonne c'était la
troisième demande de la justice et cette
fois le bureau du sénat a décidé de
lever l'immunité du parlementaire serge
dassault les juges pourront donc
longtemps qu'il ne décide sous le régime
de la garde à vue explications et
réactions avec paul bouffard rien ne
filtre de la réunion 9h30 le bureau du
sénat se retrouve aucun commentaire pas
même une image de la salle à l'écart les
journalistes attendent le verdict et les
sénateurs comme si de rien n'était
lisent les journaux 12h20 c'est bien
jean-pierre bel président du sénat qui
vient en personne annoncer le verdict
l'immunité parlementaire de serge
dassault élevée 14 membres de gauche
pour dix sénateurs ump et centristes
refuse de prendre part au vote à noter
deux absences lorsque le temps politique
on a des convictions il faut le tenir il
faut être ferme on a essayé de quelques
fois de m'en dissuader mais là le cap
était tracé je suis allé jusqu'au bout
bien sûr à la sortie les réactions sont
immédiates ça n'a duré que trente
secondes selon marie-noëlle lienemann le
vote a eu lieu tout de suite pas de
débat sur le cac dassault le sénat a
bien clarifié que l'exception l'aller ni
la levée d'immunité parlementaire c'est
l'exception quel doit être folle elle
doit elle ne doit être déclenchée que
quand il s'agit de préserver la liberté
d'expression et d'action et de vote du
parlementaire et non pas considérer
qu'on se serait une justice d'exception
dans les couloirs on attend les
commentaires ump qui n'ont pas pris part
au vote ils viendront de jean claude
carle nous avons eu un débat avant sur
la proposition du président d'un vote à
main levée nous sommes opposés un vote a
malgré parce que nous sommes attachés au
secret du vote kg dire constitutionnel
c'est indépendamment du cas de monsieur
dassault puisque le débat a eu lieu
avant nous l'aurions fait pour tout
autre un tout autre cas que celui de
monsieur dassault ironie du sort c'est
un vote à main levée qui permettrait
bien aujourd'hui aux magistrats du pôle
financier de placer l'industriel de 88
ans en garde à vue dans l' affaire
d'achat de voix à corbeil-essonnes bon
fort à faire avec quelque chose c'est
que désormais le vote se fait à main
levée c'est une bonne chose aussi pour
l'institution sénat oui mais enfin c'est
quand même surtout dramatique d'en
arriver là c'est à dire que faire moi je
vais vous dire dans cette affaire je
trouve que c'est un succession de choses
choquantes d'abord monsieur dassault
pour moi il devrait même pas pouvoir
être sénateur c'est pas normal que
quelqu'un qui a qui est à la tête d'un
groupe industriel oc puissant avec des
liens avec l'état qui sont extrêmement
forts puisque je rappelle que c'est un
groupe qui fournit des équipements
militaires notamment l'avion rafale il
est à la tête d'un journal d'un journal
le figaro et en plus de ça il se fait
élire sénateur et en plus de ça il le
fait pour échapper aux éventuels même
pas condamnation aux éventuelles
enquêtes judiciaires en essayant de se
protéger que l'immunité par l'ontt assez
insupportable et moi franchement je
trouve que à la fois la question du
cumul des conflits d'intérêts on a
beaucoup parlé ben moi je trouve que ce
cas là il devrait plus exister avec une
loi correct sur les conflits d'intérêts
et puis deuxièmement la question par
ailleurs du sénat elle est aussi posée
parce que qu'il ait fallu serpent on a
autant de fois et qu'il ya eu d'abord un
vote dont on n'a jamais su pourquoi il
agit comme ça ouais m'enfin et excusez
moi c'est cesser des pratiques
politiques qui sont plus acceptables et
nous n' allait quand même les accumulent
ces derniers temps puisque il a aussi
refusé la loi qui est resté un cumul des
mandats je comprends ce que vous dites
quand vous dites c'est le sénat qui est
en question voulait aller où exactement
le bicamérisme etc non je pense que le
nom moi je suis attaché au justement en
fait de chambre mais le sénat doit se
réformer en profondeur je les dis aussi
pour l'assemblée nationale je veux dire
nous on a eu le cas dans le précédent
mandat moi j'étais membre du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale ça n'a pas fait de
difficultés la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire qui était une députée
socialiste nous l'avons voté d'ailleurs
que nous soyons à l'époque de gauche ou
droite nous l'avons fait au delà
justement du sénat l'immunité
parlementaire elle a encore un sens
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elle doit encore
exister oui elle peut avoir un sens
parce qu'on voit bien que il peut y
avoir dans la judiciarisation de la
société parfois une instrumentalisation
par des opposants politiques de la
justice ça il faut en être conscient
donc c'est un garde-fou mais c'est un
gars de faux qu'il faut évidemment
utiliser avec raison encore une fois je
vous le dis à l'assemblée nationale
quand c'est arrivé nous avons donné
droit au juge d'entendre des collègues
par ailleurs c'est extrêmement rare donc
il faudrait pas que les français ont
conclu à cause d'un d'un énergumène si
j'ai envie de dire comme dassault que
tous les politiques cherchent à se
protéger derrière une immunité au sein
de régies on va s'arrêter cette fois sur
un sondage qui a fait beaucoup de bruit
cette semaine il concerne les idées du
front national c'est notre zone de la
semaine
bonjour et dans le serbe pour jo vous
êtes directeur de l'institut de sondages
tns sofres et un sondage pour le monde
france info car elle plus avec elle fait
beaucoup parler de lui cette semaine
notamment il concerne le raffinement des
idées du front national on est à 30
jours des élections municipales ça a
forcément un impact et un chiffre
d'abord 34% des français adhèrent aux
positions du front national ça vous a
surpris ce chiffre c'est le chiffre le
plus élevé que l'on ait mesuré depuis
trente ans on mesure c'est en fait cette
enquête depuis 30 ans c'est deux points
de plus que ce que l'on amuse à la
dernière et c'est effectivement depuis
des dizaines d'années un progrès continu
alors il faut faire attention à la
question c'est l'accord avec les idées
défendues par le front national il ya un
point qui est important défendue par le
front national
aujourd'hui ces idées et cian c'est un
des éléments qui expliquent
effectivement ce mouvement ce ne sont
des idées qui sont défendues par le
fonctionnent pas uniquement par lui et
d'ailleurs on le voit c'est au sein par
exemple de sympathisants ump que le
mouvement est le plus fort et le plus
fort en évolution par rapport à l'année
dernière puisque il gagne quatre points
de ce côté là ils sont au dessus de 40
ans qui gagne le fn ou la personnalité
de sa présidente cela vous a raison
c'est un point très précis parce que le
fn a avec un certain nombre d'idées une
capacité à capter cette ombre de
mécontentement la capacité à pouvoir
représenter effectivement ces
mécontentements de les exprimer mais il
faut quelqu'un pour les exprimer et on
voit bien l'image de marine le pen est
effectivement un des éléments qui
permettent la porosité dont on a parlé
comment vous expliquer qu'à la fois le
taux d'adhésion interne niveau
historique et finalement un partisan sur
deux de l'ump estime que le front
national est dangereux pour la société
dont ge démocratie absolument c'est la
question parce que c'est un marathon ça
n'est pas complètement contradictoire
vous pour être en accord avec des idées
défendues par et pas forcément avec le
parti en lui-même
et c'est vrai que le pivot entre les
deux hommes n'ont pas le tout à l'heure
c'est marine le pen le danger pour la
démocratie c'est un danger c'est à dire
un danger du pouvoir et c'est peut-être
la dernière barrière le dernier élément
les élections vont être aussi un moyen
de voir qu'à deux manières cette
barrière va résister c'est celle de est
ce que le front national est un parti
gouvernement est ce que le front
national au-delà de ces idées peut les
mettre en oeuvre et là il ya encore des
résistances fortes dans l'opinion
s'interroger quand vous avez pris
connaissance de ce sondage quelle
réflexion vous avez eu autres d'abord
moi je voudrais quand même bien je suis
un peu étonné qu'on fasse des sondages
d'études comme ça sur un seul parti je
pense en tout cas le journal le monde ne
fait jamais sa une sur le fait de savoir
s'il y a plus ou moins d'accord avec les
idées défendues par le parti socialiste
par l'ump ou par exemple par les
écologistes moi je trouverais ça
intéressant au moins on est une
comparaison je crains malheureusement
d'ailleurs l'adhésion aux idées
défendues par le parc ce séisme les
autres plutôt bassin par ailleurs mais
parce que le on voit bien le rejet des
partis politiques est assez fort je
pense que ce qui est intéressant c'est
en effet ce paradoxe d'un côté il y a en
effet une imprégnation un ancrage du
front national dans la société française
c'est pas une découverte 1 ça fait quand
même trente ans que ça dure là aussi
électoralement parlant avec des pics qui
sont ces dernières années en tout cas à
la présidentielle de 2012 plus fort mais
en même temps il y a encore un rejet
assez massif de propositions pourtant
phare pour le front national c'est à
dire la sortie de l'euro quelque chose
d'un peu nouveau que marine le pen a mis
les mêmes la préférence nationale et ça
je trouve ça assez intéressant serre que
je pense que même des français qui
votent pour le front national dans le
fond ne souhaite pas qu'ils gouvernent
qu'il mette en application ses idées
c'est ça qui est assez paradoxal et je
pense qu'il faut toujours redire que si
telle était l'idée était mise en oeuvre
ce serait catastrophique ces deux points
clés du discours du front national
janvier et de propositions qui sont
rejetés par les frères l'approbation
reste minoritaire c'est intéressant de
voir qui est intéressant c'est de voir
que les français on va parler des
français dans leur ensemble même s'il ya
des variations ont naturellement par
catégorie il ya une différence entre le
macro et micro j'ai dit en quelque sorte
le micro le local le quotidien et c'est
les éléments sur lequel effectuons le
front national et sa présidente ont
connu comme étant capable de porter un
certain discours qui a un certain impact
qui fait écho un certain nombre de
situations écho auprès de certaines
populations plus que d'autres
populations en difficulté les ouvriers
les chômeurs parfois les jeunes mais
c'est vrai que le maquereau lorsqu'on en
arrive aux solutions globales et vous le
6 kg et très justement effectivement que
ce soit sur l'euro que ce soit sur la
préférence nationale où que ce soit sur
d'autres thèmes de société effectivement
sans que l'on voit la société
heureusement évolué et j'allais dire
dans un sens plus ouvert vers l'autre il
ya cet équilibre là et c'est ce qui fait
sans doute la limite de la capacité
offrande du front national aujourd'hui
être ce parti potentiellement deux
gouvernements marine le pen se défend
pour dire que c'est un parti qui ne fera
qu'un parti de protestation c'est vrai
que les choses sont encore partagés dans
le pic à l'impact pour les municipales
on a vu notamment pour le parti pour
l'ump oui un impact important parce que
c'est vrai que on posait aussi une
question de manière très régulière de
cas l'attitude doivent avoir les parties
à l'égard du front national et notamment
en période électorale et on voit bien
dans la dernière enquête on a 30 7%
quand même des sympathisants de l'ump
qui disait bah oui qu'il peut y avoir
des alliances harry privilégient d'abord
les alliances au niveau local plutôt que
les alliances nationales donc c'est un
parti pas tout à fait comme les autres
mais avec lequel on est prêts à des
alliances là aussi il faut faire
attention qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pour un sympathisant ump ça peut vouloir
dire je suis prêt à faire des alliances
pour faire gagner mon candidat
ça va être très intéressant de voir de
quelle manière le front national va
évoluer il va y avoir 15 clés de
décryptage différentes en fonction du
nombre de candidats en fonction de son
score comparé aux présentes élections du
6 palier pas le même nombre de candidats
par rapport au score de marine le pen et
cetera ce seront des symboles sans doute
mais aussi le nombre de triangulaires
provoquées et au final le nombre de
conseillers municipaux qui se bat pour
être élu merci et de voir le cert alors
après les municipales le vote blanc sera
reconnu le parlement a définitivement
adopté la proposition de loi de lui dit
c'est donc aux élections européennes que
le calcul du vote blanc sera appliquée
pour la première fois ils seront contées
séparément des votes nuls et dans le
surf en un mois ce que ça peut avoir
quand même une incidence sur les votes
cette comptabilisation du vote blanc à
partir des européennes on a vu lors des
deux élections et les précédents
scrutins qu'effectivement il ya une
montée assez importante du vote mais du
nom vote hier du vote à travers le blanc
et le nul la reconnaissance à peu donné
à certains le l'idée de pouvoir
effectivement plus largement exprimé cet
élément là ça peut permettre
éventuellement de ne pas voir la
participation continue à baisser ce qui
n'est pas le cas un présidentielle mais
c'est quand même une tendance de fond ce
sera intéressant de voir quel sera
l'impact est ce que et qu'est-ce qui
vous qu'est-ce que cela voudra dire
évidement dire que c'est un vote de
rejet mais je vais voter quand même
c'est une manière macabre de garder
certains acteurs qui auraient envie de
repousser le vote comme un élément
d'expression on peut se demander quand
même à quoi ça sert s'ils sont comptés à
part aussi j'ai c'est utile par rapport
à vous savez bien on mélangeait les
blancs et les nuls et donc là on peut
dire le vote blanc moi ce que je crois
surtout c'est qu'il aurait fallu faire
et moi je continuerai à plaider pour ça
même si c'est pas toujours très
populaire faire le vote obligatoire dans
le même mouvement parce qu'à ce moment
là c'est logique c'est vous êtes obligés
d'aller voter mais s'il y avait aucun
candidat ne vous convient vous avez le
vote blanc et si on ajoute le vote blanc
à l'abstention ce que finalement c'est
ça qui va se passer on va dire le taux
d'abstention a baissé à oui mais les
blancs ont augmenté bon on ne sera pas
plus avancé donc je pense que ça c'est
quand même un problème parce qu'on le
voit à chaque élection il faut quand
même être conscient de cela tous les
français et les instituts de sondage ont
du mal d'ailleurs avec ça ne votent pas
leur taux de participation n'est pas le
même et moi j'avais fait une petite
étude sur ma commune en 2008 aux
municipales bien selon l'âge plus de 60
ans deux fois plus de taux de
participation que moins de 40 ans donc
ça pose quand même un problème
démocratique ces distorsions qui lie à
dans la participation aux élections ça
vous donner encore un peu de travail
pour les futures élections européennes
raconter tout ça merci en tout cas
d'être à l'heure est venue de nous
éclairer sur ce sondage la semaine
politique jeudi le rapport de force
entre patronat et syndicats sur le
régime des intermittents
le medef veut mettre fin à ce régime
spécial des intermittents inacceptable
pour le représentant de la cgt qui a
déchiré hier le projet de réforme du
patronat les négociations sont tendues
les intermittents ont occupé hier
pendant quelques heures le ministère de
la culture vous le voyez la ministre de
la culture aurélie filippetti a reçu une
délégation
elle a réitéré son attachement régime
d'assurance chômage des intermittents et
considérer que les propositions du medef
était la provocation les intermittents
qui ont annoncé une journée de
mobilisation nationale le 27 février
françois de rugy le medef at il franchi
la ligne rouge
si vous voulez c'est toujours le même
problème c'est que quand on d'un medef
qui ce provocateur vous avez en face des
syndicats de salariés du coup qui a
répondu sur le même ton parce que
déchiré des papiers alors qu'on est
censé être dans une négociation ça va
pas nous avancer beaucoup la question
des intermittents c'est une question
récurrente on le sait bien et en fait
c'est pas tellement bien régime spécial
serait le mode de calcul n'est pas du
tout le même que pour les autres
demandeurs d'emploi il est justifié par
les spécificités d'un certain nombre de
métiers du spectacle mais est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas des gens qui cotisent à ce
régime qui ne relève pas en réalité du
métier du spectacle et deuxièmement ce
qu'il faut voir aussi c'est que c'est
une forme de subvention à la création
culturelle il faut l'assumer mais donc
il faut que ce soit un financement qui
soit universelle et non pas un
financement uniquement sur la base des
salariés parce que là c'est vrai que à
ce moment là ça ne colle pas puisque le
régime ne s'équilibre pas après sur les
autres propositions
oui un côté que je trouve trop
provocateur pourra être encore une fois
on n'est pas dans le concret on n'est
pas dans la réalité il faut réduire le
déficit de l'assurance chômage sinon
l'assurance chômage elle va exploser un
jour ou l'autre et ça personne ne peut
le souhaiter donc il faut à la fois
réfléchir aux modes d'indemnisation et
surtout à au financement parce qu'on
sait très bien depuis très longtemps
qu'il ya un problème de financement
remettre sur la table les régimes
spéciaux pour en discuter au du monde
pour l'indemnisation du chômage c'est
pas tellement des régimes spéciaux à
part les intermittents du spectacle pour
les retraites il ya des régimes spéciaux
mais et pour l'indemnisation du chômage
et il ya plein de choses qui sont en
cause il ya certains parlent de réduire
la durée d'indemnisation bon on pourrait
l'accepter mais si il y avait plus de
perspective de retrouver des emplois
pour seulement par l'économie mais aussi
par l'aide l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi moi ce que je
constate c'est que évident pour l'emploi
est complètement débordé aujourd'hui
c'est que le comble c'est qu'un pays
comme la france a moins d'agents à
accompagner demandeurs d'emploi la
grande-bretagne la grande bretagne avec
un pays dont on dit beaucoup plus
libérale stable il ya un taux si on peut
dire d'encadrement d'accompagnement qui
est beaucoup plus élevés qu'en france
françois d'origine va changer de sujet
je vais vous emmener au cinéma cette
semaine de plus de l'hebdo s'intéresse à
un film d'animation pas comme les autres
tentent hilda cette semaine sur vos
écrans c'est l'histoire de lucas drame
amoureux de la nature elle vit dans une
forme de but végétales protégées elles
rentrent en guerre contre l'industrie
agroalimentaire contre les
multinationales qui a décidé de
concocter une céréale miracle un film
d'animation écolo rigolo mais pas que
simon barbarie vous rêvez explique tout
ça
je suis de retour
elle s'appelle hilda tente hilda
botaniste et écologistes chevronnés elle
grimpe à vélo tous les matins une
immense pente pour rejoindre sa serre
géante ce personnage titre du dernier
film d'animation de jacques rémy girerd
en salles cette semaine va devoir se
battre contre l'expansion d'une nouvelle
céréales génétiquement modifiés l'at-il
m créé par la multinationale de l'odieux
et cupide dolores est lente sont capable
de grandir face en géant a été quasi une
énergie dingue quand on n'aura pas fait
toutes nos cultures ong aux bénéfices
mandat
si l'esthétisme aux effets d'aquarelles
de ce dessin animé fleure bon la
production artisanale la problématique
manichéenne partagé entre défenseurs et
destructeurs de l'environnement dénature
quelque peu le propos des auteurs la
science et d'écologie sont trop souvent
présenté comme incompatibles et la
recherche scientifique comme un outil au
service d'intérêts mercantiles
c'est une révolution grâce à tilène la
faim dans le monde est en voie de
disparition
à l'heure où l'union européenne
s'apprête à autoriser la culture d'un
nouveau maïs ogm avec temps tilda les
enfants eux auront déjà fait leur choix
il faut les et naturel
un message écolo sous forme de fable de
quoi faire passer les idées aussi pour
les enfants oui moi j'ai pas vu le film
peut-être que j'irai le voir justement
avec mes enfants je pense que c'est
toujours bien que dans la création
cinématographique ou autre il ya
différentes idées qui s'exprime après
bon comme c'est dit c'est peut-être
caricatural et il faut pas en tirer non
plus la conclusion que ça se passe comme
ça dans la réalité c'est une fiction et
sans prendre quand même à la grande
industrie et l'agroalimentaire oui parce
que là il ya une réserve en crète qui
est en effet il y a des grandes sociétés
multinationales on le sait bien monsanto
pour ne pas la nommer par exemple qui
veut absolument imposer les maïs ogm ou
d'autres plantes ogm
envers et contre tous c'est à dire
envers et contre toutes les études qui
pourraient alerter sur certains risques
pour la santé et surtout envers et
contre toutes les décisions politiques
on voit en europe quand même ce paradoxe
insupportable ou le parlement européen
avec toutes ses composantes vote à une
large majorité le refus des cultures ogm
en france et en europe et le le la
commission européenne qui en fit fille
et qui disent on va le faire quand même
puisque au niveau des états la majorité
est moins nette que l'on appelle une loi
qui sera examiné en urgence à partir de
lundi prochain au sénat juste bon pour
interdire les ogm c'est une bonne
initiative du gouvernement c'est une
bonne initiative du gouvernement et de
la majorité puisque ce sera ce seront
des propositions de loi je pense que
c'est un signal très clair qui a envoyé
justement aux autorités européennes
alors finalement c'est à contrecoeur
parce que dans cette fable on voit des
politiques qui sont peu intéressés par
l'écologie le président n'écoute pas
hilda 7 cette femme écologiste est ce le
cas est-ce que vous vous sentez écouter
les écologistes par les hommes
politiques de façon générale ou pas les
élites françaises je parlerai pas des
autres pays mais les élites françaises
sont assez peu ouverte à l'écologie
c'est évident savez je pense que l'alena
on apprend pas beaucoup de choses sur
l'écologie et dans d'autres grandes
écoles non plus bon je pense que les
choses sont en train de changer un de
génération en génération mais
vit encore avec cet héritage très lourd
qui est en effet tout progrès technique
est un progrès toute découverte
scientifique est un progrès alors que
ces choses là bas il faut les débattre
puis ensuite il faut voir ce qu'ils
comment on peut les mettre en oeuvre
puis en même temps envie moi je crois
que c'est surtout ça le problème en
france c'est ça l'écologie en pâtit
comme d'autres c'est qu'on vit sur
l'idée qu'il faut toucher à rien donc on
est dans le défensif regarder dans le
mode domaine économique on est là
surtout préoccupés monsieur montebourg
par exemple surtout préoccupés de
défendre les entreprises des industries
existants mais pas du tout de se
projeter sur ce qui pourrait se
développer dans l'énergie on est là pour
défendre le nucléaire au lieu de se
projeter vers les énergies nouvelles qui
pourtant marche qui marche partout en
france partout en europe du travail pour
convaincre la majorité et ne vous verrez
c'est pour ça que nous sommes là des
produits à toutes nos questions d'avoir
été l'invité de parlement hebdo on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine à la
semaine prochaine michael